Chuyến thông ở rập lưu tiến, Mỹ sử kiến tổ chức của họp làm việc đủ tiến của hội đồng hoặc biên gasa.
Vong người Mỹ chiến năng hai tổ nấu Washington, thương mời để được gửi tới 20 xong cua ra của đại diện trong hội đồng.
Nhâm thảo luận về câu chia sáng sát và quả lý giải cá ra trong sự đạn hậu xung đột.
Thư điểm họp chung với thường ra em bắt đầu tháng lẽ và mà đàn của vụ giáo.
Điều đu chó là có thể anh rộng tới khả năng tham dự của một số người lãnh đạo và khoảng chức cơ cao từ các nước hủ giáo.
Hội đồng hoặc biên gasa đồng Mỹ tôi bẩy thương lập bên lệ dễ đạn kinh tị thử dưới tại đà vô sổ.
Hội hánh chứ.
Tuy nhiên, số của tháng dự lệ khi kết bằng đầu thấp hương dự kiến, chúc bất cảnh xuất hiện loại rằng
Hội đồng này có thể làm lúc mơ phải chào của lý được quốc.
Chương nhiễm quan nghệ đó các quân trưng Mỹ khẳng định.
Hội đồng hoặc biên gasa chức mắt chỉ tập trung vào dài cá ra.
Phu hợp với nghĩa của hội đồng bảo lý được quốc.
Thưa đó, giới vụ giám sát công các quả lý gà ra hội chiến trong thời hạn hành năm.